hi everyone i hope
you are staying safe and tight so i'm
very glad
today to record this talk and thank you
cell and developmental biology
virtual meeting platform for giving me
this opportunity
to present my work here so today i'm
going to present my work
that would contribute to one of the
fundamental biological question
that how does organisms control organ
size
and what are the molecular basis of
organ size regulation
so my the topic of my today's talk is
sid or g3 controls tissue size by
regulating diet one protein
turnover downstream of your key gap
so
so how does organisms control organ size
and the molecular basis of organ size
regulation so these are very puzzling
questions
and these questions are the main theme
of our studies
so broadly speaking there are two types
of processes that regulate organ growth
so systemic signals and the intrinsic
uh factors so systemic signals such as
insulin
and growth factors play a key role in
determining body and organ
size for example in drosophila
starvation or genetic mutation in
nutrient
sensing gene produce animals with
smaller organs
so these mechanisms are relatively well
defined and
are evolutionary conserved compared to
the intrinsic mechanism
so the there are internal mechanism that
control organ size
so for example a semis of
transplantation experiments in
salamander
and in drosophila have revealed about
these intrinsic
size control mechanism so in contrast to
systemic signals
so these intrinsic control mechanism are
not well understood
so genetic screens in drosophila have
identified mutations that
deregulate growth in drosophila system
which led to the discovery of key and
broadly conserved
tissue intrinsic road control signaling
pathways
including the hippo pathway or gnk
pathway
in flying and mammalian tissues hippo
singling is
conserved and potentially controls
tissue size by modulating the activity
of genes
involved in cell proliferation and cell
survival
so jnk scaffolding proteins so jnk
signaling is mediated by jnk scaffolding
proteins which play a central role
in cellular responses to apoptotic or
proliferative signals
so sunday driver sid or jnk interacting
protein g3
belongs to that family of conserved
scaffolding proteins
that bind to and facilitate jnk
signaling
so seed or g3 have been implicated in
organ size regulation
in mammals but how does g3 regulate
organ size it remains unclear
so we took advantage of we took
advantage of drosophila
wing which is a powerful system to
address
these growth related questions
so to test this hypothesis
if sit regulate drosophila organ growth
we knock down sid in developing wing
epithelium using drosophila gene
inducible system
known as gal for us system so
when you knock down sit in the wing
tissues in the wing epithelium so
this resulted in smaller adult wings
right here if you compare these
purple wings with these control means
brown wings
so this is a significantly smaller wings
compared to the control
so this piece of data it suggests that
it regulates crossover wing size
so this is very interesting and exciting
as g3 loss of function mutations are
associated with brain size defects
in mice and human but how
does g3 it regulates tissue size
so we start to determine the mechanism
so just giving you a background
information about the drosophila wing
imaginal disc so it consists of a
posterior
and an anterior compartment so the
patterning gene
and grill is specifically expressed at
this
in the posterior compartment of the wing
disc where it
induces the hedgehog expression
so hedgehog protein is trafficked to the
anterior compartment
where it activates jupiter's interrupter
ci
which is the glee version of vertebrates
so in turn this ci
it stimulates the expression of dtraf
which is a component of jnk signaling in
drosophila
so this whole event it leads to the jnk
signaling activation at this ap boundary
so this localized gnk activity acts via
the lymph domain family protein ajuba
to repress hippo's signaling throughout
the entire tissue
so it is unclear how this local effect
on hippo signaling is transferred
throughout the whole throughout the
whole tissue to promote tissue growth
so we asked that this very important
question whether cig regulates wing size
via this ci jnk hippo signaling cascade
so to address this question we
specifically knocked down
sit at the ap boundary cell where gnk is
normally active
here i'm showing in green it reduced
wing size
so if you compare the seed rna i knocked
down
at the ap boundary so compared to the
control
c rnai it reduces the wing size so
this observation it raises the
possibility that sid regulates wing size
via jnk
so to directly test this we perform
genetic epistasis experiments between
c and j and k so we expressed a potent
jnk
inhibitor to block jnk alone or
in the presence of cdrni in the ap
boundary cell
and determined the effect of these
genetic manipulation
on adult wing size so as expected
vascular dominant negative it reduced
the wing size compared to the control
so importantly blocking j and k failed
to exacerbate the small
wing phenotype caused by sid knock down
so instead these wings it resemble this
sid depleted wings so moreover
when we over express the wild-type
version of seed it restored the basket
dominant active small wing phenotype
if you compare the quantification right
here so seed over expression
it restored the seed rnai phenotype
right here
so collectively these findings argue
that seed is epistatic
to the jnk and that said it functioned
downstream of gnk
so as i explained earlier that j and k
lying to main family protein ajuba to
repress hippo signaling and promotes
wind growth
a juba represses hippo by squashing
warts
to cell cell junctions so warts is a
negative regulator of your key
so this increases your key activity
which transcriptionally stimulates
downstream transcription targets of your
keys such as cyclin e
and e3 ubiquitin ligase drosophila
inhibitor of apoptosis
which is called the diaphragm to promote
cell proliferation
and cell apoptosis simultaneously helps
hence it promotes the tissue growth so
how this your key app activation it
propagates
throughout this whole tissue it remains
unclear so we ask this question
whether it's it it acts downstream of
the your key to regulate
wing rope
so to address this we over express your
key
in the wing disc which results in
overgrown tissues
of these swear or the moderate tissue
folding phenotypes
so sit knocked down it suppressed this
severe tissue folding phenotype
yielding the wind is relatively much
smoother tissues right here
so to this moderate effect of seed rnai
is likely because
direct activation of your key is so
potent that the resulting ectopic cell
proliferation
mask the impact of sid rnai thus yorkie
requires
safe function to fully exerts its tissue
overgrowth phenotype
so in a complementary approach we
decided to activate your key by
repressing
the upstream hippokinase in contrast to
direct over your key over expression we
expected this approach activates yorkie
at physiologically relevant levels
so we asked whether knocking down seed
in this context would also repress
your key mediated tissue overgrowth so
as expected the hippo knocked down it
resulted in larger wings
so seed rnai it suppressed the large
being phenotype of hippo inhibitor
here so moreover we use the
heterozygosity of two
additional independent seed alleles uh
which is cpl 00426 or sid
deficiency so it was sufficient to
significantly suppress
uh the hippo rna large wing phenotype so
finally
the western blot analysis showed that
hippo rnai
it triggers the up regulation of seed
protein in the
wing tissues so we conclude that seed
regulates wing size
downstream of your key
so next we focused on the mechanism by
which sid
control the tissue size downstream of
your key
so we examined the expression of hippo
singling transcriptional targets
such as cyclin ee diop1 four jointed
expanded using standard transcriptional
reporter line
so interestingly expression level of
these targets were
indistinguishable between wild type and
sid rnai
expressing cells so this is unlikely
that save g3
controls wing size by regulating hippo
transcription program
so sorry
so then we explored the possibility that
safe control cellular response to hippo
signaling via
post translational mechanism and we
found that it does so
so right here when we use the diaphragm
leg c
uh to determine the expression level of
uh
the the transcription expression level
of diop one
so it had no effect on diaphone
expression
but immunostaining experiments using
diaphragm
antibodies it revealed that there is a
significant reduction
in the diaphragm protein levels
so additionally we performed the western
blood assays using lysates prepared from
these posteriorly
signaled down tissues so compared to the
so compared to the wild type
uh controls sid knocked down in only
half of the cell
was sufficient to show a reduction of
diabolo protein levels
which concern which confirms our
immunostaining experiments
so diaphore normally promotes cell
survival by antagonizing the pro
apopto pro apoptotic caspase
drunk so concordant
concordant with the loss of diaphone
protein sit knocked down in posterior
compartment cell
resulted in ectopic cell death compared
to the anterior compartment
so here you can see that more number of
cells they are dying in the posterior
compartment compared to the anterior
compartment
so these finding it strongly argue that
it promotes wing growth by stabilizing
diaphragm
activity so diet one protein it
comprises of ring finger domain that has
a e3
ubiquitin like s function this enables
diaphragm to degrade not only down
streams of
substrate but also itself to modulate
cell survival
so ring domain defective diaphragm
mutants are homozygous lethal but
heterozygous viable so we ask this
question
to what extent diop one ring mutant
heterozygosity it
restores diaphone protein levels in
sibnuckton
cell so we took advantage of
heterozygous viable diox1
ring mutation diaph1331s
and asked whether this heterozygosity
rescues diaph1c depleted cell
so you would appreciate that the
heterozygosity of diop 133 1s
allele it restored diop1 protein levels
in seed rna expressing cells so
so from here we conclude that sid it
control tissue size via diap one
so the observation this observation that
diop one bring newton
heterozygosity restore diaphragm protein
level
in sigma down south it suppose supports
that sid
normally stabilizes diaphragm by
protecting it from
proteolytic degradation
so given the loss of diet one protein in
depleted tissues and the resulting
ectopic cell death
would increase drunk activity so we
predicted that
seed depleted tissues would sensitive to
drunk dosage
such that a partial reduction of drunk
function will be sufficient to restore
wing size to some extent here you can
see that the trunk
actually it rescues this rnai phenotype
and also the diop one
ring finger a mutant it also rescues
the seed rnai phenotype you can see here
so finally we turn to the mammalian
cells to assess
whether sid similarly regulates cell
survival and cell growth in mammalian
tissues
so rnai knocked down of g3 inhibited the
growth of
hek 293 cell and caused ectopic cell
death
inflow cytometry assays mimicking that
sid knockdown mimicking the seed
knockdown phenotyping drosophila
so collectively our data highlights a
novel and conserved
seed g3 growth control mechanism our
data
indicates that silk g3 controls tissue
size downstream of the yolky gap by
regulating diop one protein turn over
hence it modulates cell survival and
ultimately tissue size
so i thank you for listening so and
i am very thankful to chabulab my p.i
eve sabu uh my colleague another person
who helped me to perform the experiments
in mammalian cells
and the graduate students and la student
in lab nadia patterson
and the undergrads emma noah and andrew
and i am very thankful
uh for these gentlemen zendrias bergman
alder thianshu hermann steller and dojia
pan
for sharing their regions with us thank
you so much